et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de partager
avec vous une conviction et pour ce
faire je vais vous inviter à être
curieux être aussi curieux que moi je le
suis et d'ajouter à cette curiosité une
petite pointe de naïveté et surtout de
l'étonnement du pseudo étonnement vous
savez le fameux ah bon ah bon la
panthère depuis environ un mois
jean raconte à ma fille l'histoire de la
panthère chaque soir elle a deux ans est
donné
j'ai trouvé ce livre dans une librairie
un livre documentaire très bien fait
avec de très belles illustrations et
l'essentiel qui est dit sur la panthère
où elle vit ce qu'elles mangent les
différentes sortes de poortere la
panthère de jama labordère noir et un
jour parfait au tome sera un reportage
animalier à la télé ma fille allait
pouvoir enfin voir ces images se mouvoir
vous savez l'ambiance des ces fameux
reportage animalier avec sa fameuse voix
off qui racontent ce que fait la
panthère donc à l'image on voit une
panthère tout seul dans la savane qui
marche seul dans la savane et la voix
off
je vais très mal la voix offre mais j'ai
peur quand même regarder la bouteyre sa
démarche feeling et séductrice pose sa
démarche féline et séductrice
mais trotter dans la tête comme ça sa
démarche féline et séductrice mais au
final sa panthère sur l'interroger
qu'est ce qu'elle dirait d'elle-même
retour lecture regardez la panthère et
sa démarche féline et séductrice allez
je fais la panthère vous avez de la
chance aujourd'hui on parle et en plus
elle parle français
donc on arrive très bien la comprendre
nous pouvons communiquer elle peut
s'exprimer démarche féline
c'est tout à fait normal je suis un
félin oui les séductrices
je marche seul dans la savane non
j'aurais plutôt voulu que vous voyez en
bout regard en ma démarche
l'animal qui à cette préoccupation
quotidienne de nourrir ses enfants
vous avez cette question et si l'animal
pouvait parler qu est ce qu ils nous
diraient c'est une question que je
m'étais déjà posée avant en fait et j'ai
se souvenir que cette aujourd'hui
partager avec vous la première fois où
je me suis demandé où je me suis posé la
question et si cet animal pouvait parler
c'est quelque chose que tout le monde a
déjà fait ici mais très peu de gens là
vous un jour et jouer j'étais petit
environ huit angles ce plu et j'ai tuer
une fourmi
je vais tuer la fourmi rouge m'a piqué
mon réflexe a été de la tuer ou à partir
de là j'ai envie de dire
tout le monde réagit comme il a envie de
réagir soit je continue à jouer ou et ça
a été mon choix je me suis dit mais
annie comme petit animal comme ça plus
de faire aussi mal c'est pas possible il
faut que je comprenne c'est quoi la
fourmi en fait c'est quoi la fourmi
c'est quoi sa définition et je me
souviens très bien qu'à la maison
mon frère et moi on avait toujours à
notre disposition sur le bureau de mon
père ce fameux dictionnaire bleu assez
gros encyclopédie donc on se dit la
source de savoir
je vais pouvoir y trouver une première
réponse à ma question c'est quoi la
fourmi et la daube j'y vais aller je
fais ma recherche
vous savez dictionnaire très simple le
principe c'est un mot une définition et
avec un peu de chance
une image bon là pas d'image mais une
définition très simple et je me souviens
que j'étais vraiment resté sur ma faim
je me souviens pas de la définition
usage peut pas vouloir dire aujourd'hui
mais j'étais resté sur ma faim
je savais qu'en fait la fourmi n'était
pas que ce qui était écrit et tout au
long de mon enfance jusqu'à maintenant
je dois dire la fourmi madrid et j'ai pu
compléter cette définition trouver dans
le dictionnaire par un imaginaire une
réputation qu'on nous donne de la fourmi
une fable à dessin animé un reportage
animalier mais au final curiosité
naïveté étonnement et 6
fourmies prouvé aujourd'hui nous parler
qu'est ce qu'elle dirait d'elle comment
se définir et l on a de la chance
aujourd'hui la lave on me parle
imaginons elle parle et à part français
encore une fois donc on peut très bien
la comprendre
elle peut très bien communiquer avec
nouveau donc
qu'est-ce que tu exactement fourmies je
me mets dans la peau de la fourmi alors
annie oui tout ce qui se dit de moi en
fait
oui il ya sûrement une part de vérité
c'est vrai que on a toujours
l'impression que je suis en mission
oui que je recherche du sucre que je
privilégie le collectif mais en fait non
non non je ne suis pas que ça je ne suis
pas tout ça en fait j'aime prendre du
temps pour moi quand tu me vois
solitaire c'est bien parce que j'ai
envie de prendre du bon temps pour moi
c'est quoi annie en fait on a trompé
dans l'histoire c'est moi la cigale donc
vous voyez ce raisonnement de se dire
qu'en fait on bâtit tout un imaginaire
autour de quelque chose sans vraiment le
questionner sans vraiment questionner
directement cette chose ça m'est resté
mais bon c'est pas le tout de
s'intéresser aux animaux à un moment
donné on s'intéresse un peu à soi et il
y a à peine deux mois j'ai fait cette
recherche sur internet
je voulais savoir c'était quoi la femme
et le réflexe est simple on va chercher
dans un dictionnaire est le plus grand
dictionnaire qui existent aujourd'hui on
sait très bien que c'est internet qu'on
y trouve de tout des images des textes
des livres tout j'allais pouvoir
assouvir la curiosité avec une pointe de
naïveté toujours et de l'étonnement
encore donc je fais cette petite
recherche est de mm e jeune femme hélas
ce moteur de recherche défini plusieurs
onglets un anglais qui détaille les
sites internet
autour de la femme sûrement puisque le
mot clé le mot clé c'est bien pharma un
deuxième membre et qui nous montre des
images de ce qu'est la femme
et ce troisième onglet donne à d'autres
régimes décider vraiment ont sélectionné
trois troisièmes anglais donc qui va me
donner une série de livres de titres de
livres autour de la femme alors
souvenez-vous ce que je vous ai dit au
tout début et je vous dis encore
toujours cette curiosité toujours une
pointe de naïveté pourquoi parce qu'on
fait moi une professionnelle de la
communication de l'information
l'algorithme de google tout ça dont je
connais la pertinence le classement des
résultats
non il ne s'agit pas de ça aujourd'hui
vraiment curiosité naïveté et étonnement
alors la liste de sites web qu'on trouve
le premier site web me paraît tout à
fait satisfaisant puisqu'il me donne une
première définition de la femme un grand
dictionnaire l'encyclopédie
participative collaborative qui me donne
donc comme première phrase
la femme est un être humain de genre
féminin et qui avant la puberté se fait
appeler fille
c'est une première définition allez je
prends et puis après je regarde des
autres sites web
hélas il y a que des sites commerciaux
shopping shopping
toute cette première page donc naïveté
je prends je me dis compléter cette
définition alors la femme est un être
humain de genre féminin qui avant la
puberté se fait appeler fille et qui
aiment le shopping deuxième onglet des
images et d'un monde
je vois donc toutes ces femmes oui alors
au delà de tout ce qui est mensurations
etc
ah bon je ne suis vraiment pas reconnu
en elle effectivement un mètre cinquante
cinq ans dans des mensurations et 90 60
90 je pense que c'est déjà et tout au
moins les 15 premières images et
d'ailleurs je vous invite à faire la
recherche et vous en bikini et c'est
vrai que ce matin vraiment ce matin en
me levant j'ai voulu saisir mais
vaguement pour aujourd'hui
j'ai ouvert mon armoire et j'ai vu cette
panoplie bikini qui sont mes vêtements
de tous les jours et je me suis dit non
non j'ai opté pour le boom ginals il
aurait très peu excentrique
en attendant je complète ma définition
la femme est un être humain de genre ces
mines
qui avant la puberté se fait appeler
filles qui aiment le shopping et qui
s'habille hantise troisième onglet les
livres et là je me dis quand même on est
un vrai sujet de recherche
on est vraiment très intrigante alors
quelques titres comme ça parce que
vraiment l'impression que tout autant en
fait la femme a vraiment questionnées
ont vraiment rien sujet à nous mêmes
la femme dans le moyen âge la femme au
siècle des lumières à les
représentations de la femme et la chasse
aux sorcières la femme tout simplement
et c'est vraiment ce ce titre qui a
retenu mon attention
la femme tout simplement d' alors là
j'ai vraiment réalisé que quand même on
avait créé ou parce que oui derrière la
machine il ya l'humain on la crée cette
réputation de la femme on l'a associé à
notre définition on a créé un imaginaire
qui m'a l'air complètement déconnecté de
ce que nous sommes vraiment parce qu'au
final quand je vous dis femme ne me
dites pas vous pensez à ces dames en
matinée m
quand je vous dis femmes ont pensé à la
grand-mère ont pensé à la mer ont pensé
aussi à la belle-mère
vous pensez à toutes ces femmes qui vous
ont construit de façon ou d'une autre et
qui continue à vous construire la femme
alors moi j'ai envie de partager
aujourd'hui ma définition de ce qu'est
la femme alors certes on peut alimenter
encore et encore je peux décliner
vraiment on est vraiment plurielle et en
même temps tout très singulière la femme
qui travaille à la femme entrepreneur
la femme dit précieuse la femme modeste
la femme qui a décidé d'être mère au
foyer la femme combattante mais vraiment
j'aimerais partager avec vous ma
définition de ce qu'est la femme parce
que pour moi il faut passer par deux
étapes la première étape est de dire
pour moi la femme c est la deuxième
étape c'est de dire je suis devenue
femme quand pour moi la femme c'est
celle qui a identifié dans sa vie le
moment où elle s'est dit oui je suis une
femme
je suis devenue femme elle est née donc
une fois elle est né une deuxième fois à
travers la reconnaissance de ce moment
là elle ne veut pas être un homme
elle ne veut pas tout faire comme un
homme elle reconnaît que l'homme et son
binôme et moi je suis devenue femme
quand pour la première fois j'ai croisé
le regard de ma première fille à
l'hôpital est vraiment en une seconde
je ne pourrais pas vous dire tout ce qui
s'est passé en une 2d mais je vous
racontais à millièmes de seconde
dans son regard en un millième de
seconde
c'était comme si j'avais vu un arrière
grand mère la grand-mère ma mère ma
belle mère mes copines toutes ces femmes
un grand cafouillage deux femmes
c'était comme si au final en un regard
dans cette femme en devenir
j'avais vu toute l'humanité entière au
féminin donc ma conviction que je
souhaite partager avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est au final il n'appartient qu'à nous
femmes de bien nous définir il
n'appartient qu'à nous d'un ferr
d'inverser la tendance actuelle
l'imaginaire actuelle il est de notre
ressort effectivement de rebondir et de
donner à voir la vérité au final un
mouvement collectif parce que chacune on
aura notre définition une intelligence
collective féminine et j'ai même plus
loin vraiment une sensation collective
décrite une véritable définition de la
femme par la femme